The DC rumor mill has cranked out a real doozy.
According to the rumor mongers at We Got This
Covered, Warner Bros. and DC Films have eyes
on a big name to portray the next version
of the Joker, who will face off against Robert
Pattinson's Batman: Johnny Depp.
"I've been considering things that begin with
the letter M. 'Moron.'
'Mutiny.'
'Murder.'
It seems unlikely that the Clown Prince of
Crime will pop up in writer-director Matt
Reeves' upcoming The Batman, in which Pattinson's
Dark Knight will make his debut.
We Got This Covered's supposed sources don't
dispute that.
Instead, they're alleging that Warner Bros.
is already looking to lock down the Joker
role for a sequel to Battinson's first outing,
and that Depp is at the top of their list
of candidates.
If we're being honest, that feels pretty unlikely
too.
As you may be aware, WGTC is not exactly a
super-reliable source of inside information.
No other media outlets have even caught a
whiff of this potential casting, and Depp
is currently under, shall we say, a little
bit of scrutiny in the media.
This all adds up to this rumor most likely
being, as they say, a bunch of hooey.
That doesn't mean that Pattinson's Bruce Wayne
won't have to contend with his cackling arch-nemesis
at some point, however.
In fact, we find it quite likely that The
Batman's inevitable sequel could introduce
the Joker.
Absent some more reputable sources, though,
we just don't think it'll be Johnny Depp in
the role.
Assuming that The Batman does get at least
one follow-up picture, it seems silly to think
that the Joker won't get involved at some
point.
There's one thing, however, that we know for
sure and if we've said this once, we've said
this a million times.
But, just in case you forgot, here's one last
reminder: It won't be the version portrayed
by Joaquin Phoenix in last year's billion-dollar
hit Joker.
"I'm-a just trying to make people laugh."
"And how's that going for ya?"
We know this for more than one reason, not
the least of which is that Joker's director,
Todd Phillips, shot any speculation on the
matter full of holes long before the flick
was even released.
Variety reports that, when asked about the
possibility of Phoenix's Arthur Fleck having
a run-in with Pattinson's Caped Crusader at
some point, Phillips flatly stated, quote,
"No, definitely not.
There will be many more Jokers, I'm sure,
in the future."
Since then, we've gotten photos from the set
of The Batman which strongly indicate that
the picture is set no earlier than the mid-2000s.
Considering that Joker was set in 1981, this
would mean that Arthur Fleck would be just
a bit too old to take on the young, sprightly
Batman who will be featured in Reeves' movies.
For that matter, the 56-year-old Depp is also
probably a bit too long in the tooth to be
seriously considered for the role of the Joker
to say nothing of fan-favorite choice Willem
Dafoe, who is even older.
No, the next actor to step into the Joker's
clown shoes is likely to be much closer in
age to the 33-year-old Pattinson.
Anyway, speaking of Joker… while Joker 2
hasn't yet been confirmed, it seems all but
inevitable given the first movie's stellar
box office performance.
If it happens to get the green light sooner
rather than later, then there's a chance that
Arthur Fleck's next big-screen appearance
could arrive before O Batman, Where Art Thou…
or whatever The Batman's sequel actually ends
up being called.
If this is the case, then our next cinematic
Joker could be part of a two-fer as the rumor
mill has also recently suggested that Joker
2 will see Arthur contending with the real
Joker, a younger, even more violent criminal
who was influenced by the events of the first
film.
The Rumor-O-Matic has even spit out one possibility
as to who might take on the role: Ben Barnes,
who portrayed Jigsaw in the Marvel Netflix
series The Punisher.
Of course, until we hear something official,
we're inclined to file this under "W.S." for
"Wild Speculation" or even "B.S.," for you
know what.
The big Bat-picture will undoubtedly become
clearer when The Batman hits the big screen
on June 25, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.